welcome to the press conference
following the European council meeting
on the situation in the Middle East um
we will uh I'll give the floor to the
president of the European Council Char
Michelle and afterwards uh to the Pres
president of the European commission
also have on the line president you have
the
floor
[Music]
Gra
on
Le
V
we had also the OCC today to address the
challenges for the days to come and for
the weeks to come and we have tasked our
Ministers of Foreign Affairs we have
tasked our ambassadors to work further
uh in different strengths of action
first we are determined to make sure
that there will be a constant monitoring
with exchange of information Among Us
between us each change of Assessments a
maximum coordination will be needed
needed to make sure that we are
extremely United on this very important
topic point two human in action and here
there are several elements that are
important first we want to coordinate a
lot with United Nations and we want to
show that we are cons that we are
coherent we think that is very important
to make possible the human access for
the people in need to make sure that
they have access to water to electricity
uh to food uh to the medicines uh they
need and here I would like to U express
my emotion feeling this recent
information foll following which an
Hospital in Gaza has been bummed with a
lot of casualties it is showing uh the
dramatic situation on the on the ground
for the people who are who are there uh
and then we have also discuss the
question of the hostages as you may know
I've had the occasion a few days ago to
meet some representatives of the
families of the victims who are hostages
uh taken by Hamas and who are in Gaza it
was a very emotional and very shocking
uh meeting uh we think we this is very
important to support the efforts made by
some in the region but some leaders in
the region who are trying to mediate to
mediate first to clarify what the status
of those hostages where they are and
what are the conditions for their
detention but also to reiterate once
again our call on the immediate release
without any conditions of all hostages
uh I had the occasion uh to have some
talks in the recent day days with some
of the leaders and I am told that many
efforts are done we support these
efforts to mediate and I hope to have
some success in that important field
another topic that we have addressed is
the evacuation of the foreign civilians
who are in Gaza uh European citizens but
not only European citizens yesterday I
had a phone call with pres Luda Lula of
Brazil who also was drawing more
attention on this question and you are
also cooperating with other countries
across the world in that important
field in a nutshell human support Human
Assistance development Aid it means that
we need also to be very firm to make
sure that the civilians must be
protected everywhere the civilians must
be
protected
Di
Z
fourth point this is the domestic
Security on the European continent in
the European Union we know very well
that uh this conflict has a lot of
resonance everywhere across the world
and is a conflict which is generating a
lot of fragmentation of divisions of
polarizations among our people people
among our societies and that's why we
need also to cooperate at the European
Union's level to try to diffuse the
tensions to try to prevent uh the
security risks and also to strengthen
the cooperation between our security
services and certainly it's very
important to make sure that we are
fighting against the hatred speeches
against the anti-Semitism and all other
forms of hatred islamophobia racism all
the speeches uh which are trying to fuel
discriminations among our citizens among
our our people uh this is also a very
firm message uh that we have expressed
all of us today and then one last
important uh topic uh for us and we need
to to work on the question this is uh
migration uh you know that uh the recent
months we have been working a lot
including at the level of the European
Council on this very important topic we
try to show solidarity with some
countries at the front line like Italy
uh for instance and we know if we take
the example of a country like Egypt with
millions of refugees in this country
that the situation can have a very
difficult impact very serious
consequences for this country and it can
also have direct consequences for us in
Europe that's why it's so important to
engage with uh Egypt this is one example
but an important example to address uh a
broad partnership with this country
including on migration including in
cooperating with Egypt to facilitate
some possible human access to Gaza which
I hope will be possible to make possible
access to
Gaza
for
Def
conf
for
thank you president president Vine you
have the floor thank you very much first
I would like to express my deep sorrow
following the recent Terror attacks that
took place in France and in Belgium and
I offer my heartfelt condolences to the
families of the victims including of
course in
Sweden we met today at this European
Council VTC because of another heus
terror attack perpetrated by Hamas on
Israel
1,400 Israelis and other Nationals
massacred in one single day Hamas taking
close to 200
hostages we call for the immediate
release in Israel I spoke to
families that have for example the 82
year-old grandmother abducted by
Hamas a mother that was desperately
looking for her 22-year-old daughter
abduct Ed by Hamas from the festival in
Israel in face of this it is clear to
everyone that Israel has the right to
defend itself in line with International
and humanitarian law but that is not
all Hamas terror is also bringing
immense suffering to the Palestinian
people and let me be very
clear I wasn't fright in Israel in the
kibuts kafar AA
this was the first place I went to I saw
the blood I saw the burn down houses I
saw children's toys no child will ever
play with them
anymore there in the presence of the
speaker of the knesset I said very
clearly that it is Hamas who are the
terrorists not the Palestinian people so
we have to care for the Palestinian
people and their humanitarian
needs there is no contradiction in
standing with Israel in
solidarity and acting for the
humanitarian needs for the
Palestinians on Saturday I spoke to
Antonio gutes I informed him that the
commission is tripling the humanitarian
aid for Palestinians in this year we're
also establishing an air bridge to Egypt
close to Gaza in order to be in a
position to quickly deliver AC Aid
across the
border we are in contact with the
Egyptian authorities to enable our Aid
to enter Gaza from Egypt and commission
staff is in Egypt to prepare for the
delivery of humanitarian Aid into Gaza
we're also explaining to the Israeli
authorities that providing water to Gaza
is essential this is a basic human
right on the broader issue of financial
support and development aid for
Palestine I am not aware of any EU
funding going to any terrorist
organization and it has to stay like
this and this is why we're conducting an
internal review and will coordinate with
member states carrying out their own
reviews on The Wider Regional
context I've been recently talking to
several Arab
leaders all were very clear about the
importance of our EU
funding and that these events have the
potential to draw the entire region into
conflict and this would put in doubt the
positive impact of our entire
neighborhood funding just as an example
about 10% of the entire budget of the
Palestinian authorities funding comes
from the European Union or take Egypt
Egypt is already hosting substantial
numbers of
refugees we must work and support Egypt
in this current crisis and establish a
comprehensive
partnership allow me to conclude on a
last crucial
thought some believe that they can
distract us from supporting Ukraine and
that we have to choose whom to support
we will prove them wrong we stand by our
friends in their time of need for as
long as it takes
it is important that our proposal for
the mff now is being
processed and lots of support for
Ukraine is in the making because we know
that they are fighting for our values
and we stand by them for as long as it
takes thank you President we will
continue with uh questions from the room
I'll take two questions from the room on
one from on line
Susanna
um thank you Susanna fresh say I see
Portugal uh president uh you mentioned
the attack against uh these hospital so
I suppose you have more info and that
this is uh
confirmed um so I would like to
understand is this um respecting the
humanitarian or the international law so
what is your view and I also would like
to understand when do you expect Egypt
to open the border and to let also the
Europeans to come out and to also to
provide the and to move forward with the
humanitarian corridors thank
you on on the First on on the first
question we we got this information when
we were together uh during this virtual
meeting with the leaders it seems to be
uh to be confirmed and an attack against
a civilian infrastructure is not in line
with the international law um this is um
this is uh my first point on Egypt um I
just mentioned because this should be
clear for everyone in Europe that for
Egypt there's a very clear position on
the idea that they do not intend to
allow people from Gaza to leave Gaza and
to and to and to be hosted in Egypt but
we are working with all the leaders in
the region to try to organize the
evacuation of foreign civilians point1
and we are also working with all the
leaders of the region in order to make
possible the human access to be able to
provide to the people uh in need uh the
what what what what they need and to and
to and to meet uh their basic
needs president Vine would you like to
add or we go to we take we can take the
next question because I have just been
informed about the incident I need
confirmation I cannot comment in at this
moment but on uh the question of Egypt
as I said commission staff is on the
ground in Egypt working intensively
on facilitating that the humanitarian
Aid that we are now bringing I think we
start with the two first flights this
week still uh to Egypt uh can proceed uh
into Gaza this is of utmost importance
that we now deliver this humanitarian
Aid
Andrew Andrew G from Reuters a question
for both um presidents um president
Michelle you stressed the importance of
a common EU position can I ask you both
if you you endorse the view of the high
representative which he expressed after
a meeting of the foreign ministers that
Israel has already contravened
International humanitarian law by
imposing a total blockade on Gaza thank
you a total a total Siege uh when uh you
cut the basic infrastructure when you
you cut access to water when you cut
electricity we don't when you don't if
you don't allow food to uh to be
delivered this is not in line with the
international
Al okay we'll go over to president Vine
if you want to add something otherwise
we go to the third question yes I think
it is very important uh to look at the
statement we had agreed on today that is
the leader statement and it
concludes uh the position of the
European Council of which I am a
member mind daas uh from Lithuania you
have the floor U you rais ra your hand
online yeah thank you thank you so much
for this
opportunityis from Lithuanian National
radio and television I have a question
to both presidents was yesterday's
terror attack in Brussels discussed or
at least mentioned in the discussion
about internal EU security and uh today
French president said that islamist
terrorism is basically returning to
Europe do you share this assessment and
uh uh you know do you share this
assessment that the threat of terrorist
attacks in the EU is bigger now than it
was for example before Israel conflict
thank
you
point
what we have seen these days is that
terror is resurfacing and the member
states are highly Vigilant to this topic
um the more it is important that we do
everything possible to deescalate in the
region um affected to deescalate the
tensions in The Wider region and to do
everything to go back to uh the
discussions that had been so fruitful
between Arab countries and Israel to
support this process as much as possible
and to do everything as I said to um
care for the humanitarian needs of those
people who are at the moment being uh in
need of support uh not only in Gaza
Strip but also in that region
thank you I think with this concludes
the press conference thank you very much
for coming so
late